entre universitaires un sondage étonnant
les deux tiers des étudiants sont
satisfaits de leurs études
georges marchais à tf1 tournant du parti
socialiste vers la droite le parti
communiste ne modifiera pas sa position
d'un pouce les français redécouvrent
gustave courbet au grand palais plus de
150 peintures et dessins pour la plus
grande exposition de la saison
bonsoir on se plaint quelques fois dans
le public de ce que la politique
envahissent le petit écran je suis le
premier à reconnaître que leurs proches
n'est pas toujours injustifiées et
d'ailleurs un parlementaire et non des
moindres puisqu'il s'agit de robert
andré vivien député rpr membres du
conseil d'administration d'antenne 2 a
demandé aujourd'hui très officiellement
des restrictions dans une question
écrite au premier ministre un jour sans
politique à la télé et à la radio comme
jadis il y avait les jours sans alcool
en fait robert andré vivien traduit
assez bien le degré de saturation
politique atteint par les
téléspectateurs et les auditeurs encore
faudrait-il que le jour sans politique
choisie soit le bon jour et ce ne serait
pas le cas aujourd'hui par exemple
oui lorsque compte tenu de l'enjeu que
représente pour le pays des élections de
mars 78 le débat est réellement un débat
de fond il ne faut pas s'en plaindre
il faut s'en féliciter de ce point de
vue aujourd'hui tf1 est au coeur de
l'événement double événement même
puisque georges marchais en direct du
bureau politique du parti communiste
dans notre édition de 13h a prononcé un
véritable réquisitoire contre le parti
socialiste est que dans une demi heure
c'est raymond barre qui répondra aux
questions de mes confrères de la
rédaction
ce grand intérêt le grand intérêt de la
continuité de ces deux moments de
l'histoire politique dans la même
journée sera d'avoir entendu georges
marchais accusé le parti socialiste de
s'être engagé dans un tournant à droite
et ensuite raymond barre a mené je le
présume à commenter ses propos récents
la crise de la gauche a profondément
modifié le paysage politique de la
france ce qui n'est pas l'avis de tout
le monde dans la majorité
ce sera la première fois que le premier
ministre en tout cas s'exprimera
officiellement sur cette crise de la
gauche et s'ils manient la pelle et la
pioche pour déblayer ce que michel debré
ap laitière
le champ de ruines de l'union de la
gauche il pourra dire aussi quels outils
il entend employer pour aller au charbon
selon sa propre expression c'est à dire
pour s'engager dans la stratégie
politique
revenons à georges marchais il est venu
à notre édition de 13 heures après un
comité central du parti communiste qui a
adopté une résolution où figure en
toutes lettres la gravité du tournant à
droite du parti socialiste tournant qui
ouvre la porte à la possibilité d'un
replâtrage du pouvoir ajoute le texte
qui appelle toutes les organisations du
parti communiste a engagé un vaste débat
démocratique à l'échelle nationale à
travers des milliers de discussion de
contact de réunions grandes et petites
les communistes vont faire connaître
leur position et leur action en faveur
d'une politique nouvelle
ils porteront en priorité leurs efforts
vers les entreprises vers les
travailleurs les travailleuses dont
l'intervention est décisive
fin de citation voici maintenant l'un
des passages de l'interview de georges
marchais sur tf1 tout à l'heure à 13h
qui résume le mieux les sentiments et la
position du parti commandes est stable
devant la situation est sérieuse elle
est grave elle est préoccupant parce
qu'il y à ce tournant à droite du parti
socialiste qui je le répète trouve son
expression dans le refus d' actualiser
le forum commun dans l'abandon
d'engagements pris en 1972 mais il ya en
même temps la volonté réaffirmée
clairement par notre comité central de
ne pas bouger d'un pouce dans la
politique qui est la sienne pour les
objectifs que je viens de rappeler à
l'instant que la crise qui sévit en
france
elle sévit dans tous les pays
capitalistes d'europe et que dans la
plupart d'entre eux en allemagne en
grande bretagne en norvège au danemark
hollande en belgique récemment la
bourgeoisie a eu recours à la social
démocratie pour essayer pour gérer
plutôt la crise sur le dos des
travailleurs et bien disons que la
grande bourgeoisie française considère
elle aussi que le moment est venu d
essayer d'entraîner
le parti socialiste dans cette voie vous
soupçonnez d'accepter voilà force nous
est de constater que le parti socialiste
n'a pas été insensible mais aux compères
qui l'a prêté l'oreille à cette pression
qui s'est exercée sur lui à la fois de
l'intérieur et de l'extérieur
bien que georges marchais a refusé de
parler de procès il a préféré utiliser
les termes d' analyse politique fine et
serré c'est bien le parti socialiste qui
est aujourd'hui au banc des accusés
tel un homme qui démonte un mécanisme
pièce par pièce georges marchais n'aura
jamais été aussi précis il ne sera
jamais allé aussi loin dans des
accusations portées contre le parti de
françois mitterrand c'est à la fois
l'accusation faite aux socialistes de
pencher à droite mais c'est aussi
calendrier en main l'accusation fait au
premier secrétaire socialiste et à tel
ou tel de ses lieutenants de n'avoir eu
jusqu'ici que des comportements
résolument anti unitaire georges
marchais qui ne veut pas ouvrir
prématurément la campagne électorale a
d'autre part répété que le problème des
désistements aux prochaines élections
n'est absolument pas à l'ordre du jour
les communistes en discuterons au cours
d'une conférence nationale
une sorte de mini congrès qui devait se
tenir le mois prochain et qui a été
reportée en janvier 78
à cette date le parti communiste fera le
point mais on peut d'ores et déjà penser
que les désistements entre partenaires
de la gauche promettent d'être
difficiles
en cas de non accord sur la
réactualisation du programme comme du
côté socialiste ce n'est pas non plus la
décrispation loin de là claude estier
secrétaire national du ps parle
aujourd'hui dans l'hebdomadaire l'unité
des attitudes grotesque du parti
communiste ce n'est pas parce que
georges marchais répète sans fois une
contre vérité écrit claude estier
qu'elle devient une vérité et franz
humer et françois mitterrand qui
participent aujourd'hui en angleterre au
congrès travailliste de brighton a eu
cette phrase les sarcasmes et les
invectives du parti communiste ne feront
certainement pas avancer les choses bref
jamais jusqu'à aujourd'hui la gauche
n'est apparu aussi proche du divorce ou
de la rupture mais en matière de
politique les coups de théâtre sont
toujours possibles
les élections législatives c'est pour
dans 24 semaines 24 semaines au cours
desquelles il peut encore se passer
beaucoup de choses dans les deux sens
oui donc dents à plusieurs reprises
georges marchais a fait la critique du
comportement de françois mitterrand que
ce soit lors de
face à face avec raymond barre ou au
congrès socialiste de nantes ou encore
pendant les négociations sur le
programme commun je vous rappelle que
demain soir françois mitterrand sera
notre invité ici dans ce journal
ce qui lui donnera l'occasion de
répondre à la fois georges marchais et
aussi à raymond barre
quoi qu'il en soit les variations du
paysage politique l'analyse de la crise
à gauche donne parfois des résultats
contradictoires dans les raisonnements
des leaders de majorité à france inter
et successivement jacques chirac a dit
que l'hypothèse d'un gouvernement
socialo centriste était tout à fait
absurde et qu'elle conduira la france
dans la pire des situations et
jean-jacques servan-schreiber a dit que
ce qui serait absurde
ce serait de fermer la porte aux
socialistes et jean pierre soisson
ajoute dans une chronique au journal le
monde
pas question de récupération mais la
majorité ne saurait s'enfermer dans une
forteresse
j'ai encore à vous donner de nouvelles
politiques importantes valéry giscard
d'estaing prononcera dans un peu plus
d'un mois le 8 novembre devant le
conseil constitutionnel une allocution
consacrée à la protection des libertés
et des droits des citoyens et cela à
l'occasion d'une cérémonie
exceptionnelle en présence du
gouvernement des représentants du
parlement et des plus hautes autorités
de l'état
certains croient pouvoir dire
aujourd'hui que ce discours sur les
libertés pourrait être repris comme l'un
des thèmes essentiels de la campagne
électorale dans la majorité
et puis la deuxième nouvelle politique
concernant un homme qui fut le rival de
monsieur giscard d'estaing aux élections
présidentielles de 74
il s'agit de jacques chaban delmas dont
la réserve à l'égard du rpr n'en fait
pourtant pas un solitaire politique le
président de la république l'a chargé
d'une mission sur l'état des relations
entre la france et israël et cela à un
moment délicat des relations d'israël
avec le reste du monde
le premier ministre monsieur begin a été
invité officiellement à venir en visite
en france
la tension est montée très vite dans les
compteurs électriques depuis que le
ministre de l'industrie rené monory hier
soir à l'assemblée nationale a parlé de
la vérité des prix de l'énergie et de la
limitation du tout électrique
comme toujours quand on parle
d'électricité on a du mal à se mettre
parfaitement au courant
on a parlé par exemple de la suppression
du tarif de nuit c'est faux monsieur
monory a tenu à le préciser aujourd'hui
après une tempête dans les crânes des
utilisateurs et des professionnels de
l'équipement électrique une tempête qui
failli faire disjoncter les nerfs des
adeptes du tout électrique
c'est ce qu'on appelle un tollé général
et c'est pour ça que nous faisons points
ce soir avec jacques poulx les
déclarations du ministre industries ont
déclenché un véritable tollé chez ceux
qui s'étaient suivant les conseils
publicitaire de l'edf équipés en tout
électrique le cancer des lamentations
contre la suppression du tarif jour nuit
contre la disparition des deux tranches
de tarification ne s'est pas fait
attendre
devant la réaction des particuliers et
d'edf monsieur maunoury a dû préciser
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de points
il n'est pas question par exemple de
toucher au tarif de nuit
en revanche l'action du gouvernement
portera sur la suppression progressive
des tarifs réduits qui incitait et qui
encouragés à la consommation
d'électricité aux heures creuses du jour
par exemple ceux qui ces trois dire à
part une augmentation sur nos factures
d'électricité en 1978 de vous aurait
vraisemblablement comme en 1977 une
augmentation des tarifs et des f qui
seront conformes aux objectifs du plan
barre 6 ennemis 7% en gros on verra je
verrai à ce moment là c'est le premier
qui le décidera et d'autre part vous
aurez sans doute à cause de cette
réduction progressive des tarifs
dégressifs peut-être une augmentation de
2 à 3%
et puis peut-être qu'en 79 une nouvelle
un nouveau réajustement permettra là
encore un certain rattrapage
enfin tous ceux qui choisiront le tout
électrique perron à partir du printemps
prochain
une taxe d'installation de 3 à 4000
francs
c'est donc un sérieux coup de frein au
développement du tout électrique en
france un système qui représente
aujourd'hui un logement neuf
surtout la seule chose que nous
souhaitons c'est ne pas intensifier trop
rapidement le tout électrique car notre
installation nucléaire ne sera vraiment
opérationnel étant
1985 1986 nous aurons donc des périodes
81 82 83 un peu plus difficile à passer
et si nous ne faisons pas preuve de
modération en ce moment dans ses
installations qui resteront je vous
lundi qu'à 35% de la construction de
logements deuil dans les prochaines
années nous risquerions une rupture et
je pense qu'à ce moment là les français
auraient serait en droit de reprocher au
gouvernement d'avoir mal prévu le
développement de l'électricité
nous l'avons constaté cela fait
plusieurs mois déjà que les acquéreurs
d'appareils ménagers hésitent à
s'équiper en tout électrique
voici ce qu'en dit le responsable d'un
magasin spécialisé que nous avions
davantage de demande en électricité est
à l'heure actuelle on revient davantage
vers le mythe c'est à dire gaz
électricité toute cette affaire aura eu
au moins le mérite d'attirer l'attention
des pouvoirs publics et des
consommateurs sur le danger qu'il y à a
gaspillé l'énergie électrique énergie
que l'on ne paie d'ailleurs actuellement
pas à son véritable prix et oui et quand
monsieur monory prêché la vérité des
prix ce qu'il est dans une autre vérité
seul de l'énergie du prix d'énergie dans
le monde
la facture pétrolière de la communauté
européenne augmentera de plus de 12
milliards de francs en 77 viennent de
constater les ministres 10 19 pays de l'
agence internationale de l'énergie où la
france ne siège pas d'ailleurs on
prévoit déjà la limitation des
importations de pétrole
en 85 après plusieurs grands voyages
officiels en iran à la suite desquelles
ces dernières années on a parlé de
contrat fabuleux pour la france il a
fallu qu'un envoyé spécial du président
de la république michel poniatowski lui
même à y faire le point sur ce qui était
réalisable
effectivement monsieur poniatowski est
revenu avec deux importants accords en
poche
l'iran est disposé à conclure
positivement et à très bref délai la
négociation en cours pour la commande à
la france de deux centrales nucléaires
de 900 mégawatts
le shah d'iran a précisé qu'ils étaient
disposés aussi à ouvrir des négociations
pour la commande de quatre autres
centrales et cela en contrepartie bien
sûr d'achat de pétrole iranien et
d'autre part une décision était prise
par l'iran celle d'équipé sa compagnie
aérienne d'avions airbus dix à douze
appareils pourraient être commandés au
cours des prochaines arrête de concours
des prochaines années une première
tranche de quatre avions de en location
de longue durée et de acheter ferme sera
traité à la fin de l'année ces contrats
étant en discussion depuis des mois
souvenez vous il ya eu l'époque des
superlatifs les dollars du pétrole
devant être la source pour l'industrie
française de contrats extraordinaire
d'ailleurs avec d'autres pays que l'iran
jusqu'à 60 milliards de francs rien que
pour l'iran 10 et on est bien les choses
ont traîné la désillusion s'est mise à
ramper
désormais plus personne ne se hasarde à
avancer des chiffres alors des mirages
ces contrats fabuleux un dossier d'un
avait l'air des contrats fabuleux avec
l'iran il y en a eu par exemple plus
d'un milliard de francs pour cinq mille
cinq cents logements à téhéran les deux
premières centrales nucléaires
présenteront à elle seule un marché de
11 milliards
malgré tout on reste loin des 60
milliards annoncés et c'est logique 60
milliards c'était le montant de tous les
projets iranien auquel auraient pu
participer des entreprises françaises
certains traînent en longueur ou ne
verront même pas le jour
et puis d'autres pays étrangers étaient
sur les rangs alors finie l'euphorie les
pays producteurs de pétrole investissent
moins que prévu
les pays de l'est commencent à être
équipée enfin avec la crise des
économies la concurrence que se livrent
les fournisseurs de biens d'équipement
du sinn clé en main s'est faite plus
arbres de nouveaux concurrents sont
apparus comme l'espagne pour la grosse
chaudronnerie ou encore la yougoslavie
pour la sidérurgie
il faut le savoir les prix français sont
souvent maintenant de 20 à 40% supérieur
à ceux qui figurent dans les offres les
plus alléchantes
au total l'an dernier les français ont
tout de même signé plus de 400 contrats
de plus de 10 millions de francs dans le
monde exemple deux centrales nucléaires
6 milliards de francs pour l'afrique du
sud deux usines d'aromatiques 2
milliards pour l'union soviétique
mais la manne semble-t-il commence à se
tarir est-ce catastrophique
tous ces contrats fabuleux coûte cher au
trésor public qui doit offrir des
garanties aux exportateurs contre les
risques qu'ils courent et des conditions
de crédit ultra avantageuses aux
acheteurs une nouvelle politique du
commerce extérieur se dessine
établir un courant d'affaires régulier
avec des contrastes certes plus modeste
mais un volume d'affaires beaucoup plus
conséquent un exemple andré rossi
ministre du commerce extérieur revient
aujourd'hui du venezuela un pays où la
france a été battue par les espagnols et
les canadiens pour la construction d'une
ligne de chemin de fer de 740 km pad
annonce de contrat fabuleux mais les
exportations françaises vers le
venezuela ont progressé de 58% en six
mois les étudiants retournent aux études
il rentre doucement doucement
contrairement à la rentrée scolaire la
rentrée universitaire s'échelonne sur
plus d'un mois les instituts
universitaires ont ouvert leurs portes
cette semaine il y aura ensuite les
facultés de médecine les universités
scientifiques de droit des lettres et
ainsi de suite jusqu'au 3 novembre
environ
notre confrère l'étudiant que voici
vient de publier un guide à l'occasion
de cette rentrée un guide que vous
trouverez lundi dans les kiosques et qui
contient beaucoup de renseignements
pratiques comment un étudiant peut-il
trouver une chambre à paris comment
obtenir une bourse etc
mais l'étudiant publie surtout un
étonnant sondage réalisé auprès de 5000
jeunes sur les 900 milles qui iront à
l'université cette année
un sondage qui loin de nous tracer le
portrait de l'étudiant français
fantaisiste marginal voire paresseux
comme certains le décrivent nous le
montre au contraire comme un personnage
fort sérieux le détail de ce sondage
avec l'éternel étudiant qu'est dominique
fleury ont leurs mains les événements de
mai 68
l'étudiant n'a pas il faut bien dire
très bonne presse souvent à tort
d'ailleurs il est considéré comme un
personnage inquiétant contestataires
bien plus préoccupée de politique de ses
études
aujourd'hui c'est presque de l'histoire
mais l'image de l'étudiant faut bien le
dire a peu évolué les français
les adultes en général ont de mauvais
rapports avec les étudiantes et
étudiants qu'ils connaissent très mal
à la vérité l'étudiant 77e sondages le
démontrent est travailleur écologiste
fait peu de politique
et surtout est très préoccupée par son
mari une première constatation première
sur fait les deux tiers des étudiants
interrogés sont satisfaits des études
qu'il poursuit et si deux étudiants sur
trois ne vivent plus chez leurs parents
en revanche ils entretiennent avec eux
de bonnes relations
voir d'excès 40% sont plus de patron de
cadres supérieurs et professions
libérales 8,5 son fils de prix 90 % des
étudiants interrogés n'adhère à aucun
mouvement politique ou syndicale 25 %
n'ont pas envie de voter aux élections
de mars
78 en cas d'élection présidentielle
prendre 2 points 5 pour son ventre rond
pour un candidat écologiste 25,8 pour
françois mitterrand 13,3 pour giscard
d'estaing 6,7 pour jacques chirac et 8,6
pour georges marchais 50% des étudiants
interrogés n'achète qu'un livre par mois
et 46 % reconnaissent qu'ils aiment
avant tout lire des romans policiers
mais l'auteur le plus lu reste double m
emile zola suivi de camus sartre et
boris vian 67% des étudiantes 81 % des
étudiants ont eu des relations sexuelles
mais sept pour cent des étudiantes ont
avorté au moins une fois
25 % des étudiants ont déjà fumé des
drogues douces 2,3 pour cent en prennent
régulière enfin la vision de l'avenir
une vision pessimiste une grande
préoccupation
le chômage plus de 60% ne pense pas
trouver facilement du travail
bien sûr ce n'est qu'un sondage mais il
montre que les étudiants d'aujourd'hui
ont les mêmes préoccupations
le même comportement et les mêmes
inquiétudes devant l'avenir que les
jeunes loups prix visite surprise du
président de la république cet après
midi au centre de formation
professionnelle des adultes de lardy
dans la région parisienne il voulait
voir comment ça fonctionne sur le
terrain la fp1 et ses 4600 enseignants
forme chaque année 80 mille ouvriers
qualifiés professionnels et techniciens
hélas le président a fait une première
constatation importante au micro de
françois go à la fin des stages 85 % des
gens qui les suivent trouvent un emploi
tout de suite
deuxième chose que je trouve frappante
c'est l'effort d'adaptation de la
pédagogie parce qu'il est certain que
tous et toutes ces professions ces
métiers évoluent et qu'il est
indispensable que la formation évolue et
qu'elle se tienne à jour naturellement
de tous les nouveaux progrès et enfin
c'est le l'intérêt que les stagiaires
portent à leur formation
justement vous avez des contacts avec
les stagiaires lors lequel vous a le
plus intéressé le plus marqué je suis
venu pour faire passer un examen mais
pour savoir ce que pensaient les
stagiaires à la liga deux catégories
stagiaires fayyad et des travailleurs
qui ont été licenciés pour cause
économique qui exerçait d'ailleurs des
métiers variés puisque les athées
transporter les autres étaient même
comptable et qui ce qu'ils font on
choisit cette nouvelle formation
professionnelle avec un désir de
promotion puis l'autre chose frappante
parmi les jeunes
c'est certainement le désir de beaucoup
d'entre eux de s'installer eux mêmes à
leur compte et notamment dans des
métiers comme ceux du bâtiment de
travailler ce soient eux mêmes soient
dans de petites équipes et donc
d'utiliser directement leur formation
professionnelle des nouvelles de ce
genre eh bien d'abord les vendanges
c'est parti dans le languedoc roussillon
en bourgogne dans le bordelais en
gironde malgré l'été pourri un mois de
septembre exceptionnel à sauver une
partie de la récolte 77 et les vendanges
ont commencé avec un peu d'avancé les
raisons et les raisins et tente à
maturité en quantité la récolte sera de
40 à 50% de celles des dernières la
qualité elle sera correcte voire bonnes
affirme les viticulteurs à l'unesco pour
la première fois un fonctionnaire d'un
pays socialiste en l'occurrence la
roumanie est empêchés de regagner son
poste à paris les autorités de son pays
accuse monsieur du mythe rescue de ne
pas avoir versé à l'état la moitié de
ses émoluments en devises comme l'obligé
la loi roumaine
cette sanction paraît disproportionnée
aux yeux de la direction générale de
l'unesco qui proteste avec véhémence à
faire du détournement du dc 8 de la
japan airlines l'algérie a refusé
officiellement l'extradition des cinq
pirates de l'air et des six extrémistes
libéré il en va de même pour la rançon
de 300 millions de centimes
en revanche les pirates sont passés à
côté d'un trait
en effet près de 100 millions de
centimes en diamant se trouvaient à bord
de l'avion et à alger tout simplement
une hôtesse au courant a pris les
paquets sous son bras avant de débarquer
encore une action anti concorde de la
part de l'autorité portuaire de new york
qui demande à la cour d'appel de l'état
de surseoir pendant 30 jours à sa
décision d'autoriser le supersonique à
atterrir à kennedy airport de les voir à
présent des images de monsieur croissant
de mettre 300 films et dans la prison de
la santé dans la cour de la prison
pendant une promenade
l'avocat d'amanda bader est détenu
depuis le 30 septembre il a été arrêté à
la demande des allemands qui tente de
réunir un dossier suffisamment solide
pour obtenir l'extradition
pendant ce temps monsieur hans martin
schleyer en est à sa cinquième semaine
de séquestration les assassins de la
vieille dame de valleroy ont été arrêtés
par les policiers de nancy il s'agit de
deux mineurs de 17 ans ils ont tué pour
la volée et ont martyrisé madame orsec
pour lui faire avouer où elle cachait
son argent
un homme de 23 ans également été
interpellées l'avaient indiqué le cou
aux deux jeunes voyous grave accident au
palais des expositions de la porte de
versailles la chute de tuyaux de
chauffage en essais de fonctionnement a
tué un ouvrier et brûlé gravement cinq
autres employés toutefois cela ne
retardera pas l'ouverture du salon equip
auto qui ouvre bien donc demain au
public à partir de 10 heures un autre
salon s'ouvre également à la porte de
versailles celui d'ici clés de la moto
et le clou de l'exposition et ce vélo
qui coûte plus de 1 million de centimes
un petit bijou de 7 kg 700 un nouveau
tube de trois dixièmes
une vraie merveille n'est pas à la
portée de toutes les bourses le prix
nobel de littérature 77 a été attribué
au poète espagnol vie santé alexandre
membre de l'académie royale espagnole il
est l'auteur d'une oeuvre importante
dont on connaît en france que la
destruction ou l'amour qui a été édité
chez fédérop ce livre lui valut le prix
national de littérature la plus haute
distinction littéraire de son pays et
jacques le grime affirmé qu'un choix de
ses poèmes de poésie total est
actuellement sous presse aux éditions
gallimard
ce n'est pas par masochiste que nous
vous montrons les bus de manchester
contre saint-etienne mais bien parce que
beaucoup d'entre vous les voies pour la
première fois 2 0 donc pour manchester
et l' aventure européenne de
saint-etienne s'est terminée hier soir à
plymouth
mais il ne faut pas tirer sur les verts
comme on dit leur performance depuis
quatre ans ont relancé le football
français et puis il y à bastia lens et
nantes qui reste qualifiée alors il ya
de l'espoir
donc ce deuxième juge pour gagner le
tiercé il fallait jouer le 5 le 13 et le
disent ils rapportent dans l'ordre pour
5 francs
quinze mille 445 francs et dans un ordre
différent toujours pour 5 francs 2057 le
temps demain et bien il sera très
nuageux avec des pluies ou des averses
parfois accompagnées d'orages de l'eau
en abondance sur les régions
méditerranéennes et sur les montagnes de
la moitié sud est
temps variable à l'extrême ouest les
vents seront assez forts dans le midi de
fortes rafales se produiront sous les
orages et les températures seront en
baisse surtout dans l'ouest de la france
courbet courbet au grand palais jusqu'au
2 janvier 1978
ce sera l'une de ses expositions phares
qui déplace les foules et pas seulement
les foules parisienne la province
montera à paris pour ce grand peintre du
19e siècle et c'est tant mieux que la
peinture obtiennent parfois de tels
succès populaire c'est avec adam
souligné que nous allons faire une
première visite à cette exposition
courbet c'est à partir de peintures
monumentales près de quatre mètres sur 7
que se déroule l'exposition courbet à
paris dans les galeries du grand palais
si l'atelier du peintre la l'enterrement
à ornans peut-être sa plus célèbre
peinture
ornans en franche comté ou installé à
paris il ne cessa de retourner calmes à
la source afin de retrouver les genres
de son pays ses troupes peau sa maison
familiale
la chambre de sa naissance et la grande
cheminée devant laquelle il s'est plu à
peindre cette fin de repas dans la calme
réflexion de la vie populaire qui le
mena tout naturellement dans le sillon
des idées sociales et politiques
exprimées par proudhon dont il fit ce
portrait et la mena dans une même
logique a présidé la fédération des
peintres de la commune de paris
en conséquence de quoi il fut en 1871
injustement condamné en tant
qu'instigateur de la démolition de la
colonne vendôme surmonter le l'éffigie
de l'empereur
ceci sur décision prise par un conseil
de guerre
siégeant à versailles d'où son
emprisonnement
l'obligation de quitter la france pour
la suisse et sa mort en exil le 31
décembre 1877 jamais gustave courbet de
devait revoir cette ville d'ornans qu'il
avait peinte avec tant d'amour ni revoir
ses forêts les biches et laissait ni
connaître à nouveau le goût intense de
la ville caractérisée sa peinture où se
côtoyaient la beauté des corps féminins
et le travail de ce peuple dont ils
étaient issus qu'il avait tenté mais
cent ans après sa mort l'oeuvre de
courber le bon peintre est célébré à
paris dans les galeries du grand palais
mais cet art nom que son souvenir
demeure dans le murmure de l'eau
voilà monsieur le premier ministre
raymond barre est maintenant dans notre
studio il va répondre tout à l'heure aux
questions de nos confrères de la
rédaction
l'événement à 20h30 fin tout de suite
après la publicité après ce journal
bonne soirée à tous au nom de toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité dernier
journal jean pierre pernaut vers 23h15
merci